now finally let's talk about the
occasional and the cultural segmentation
options the occasional segmentation
focuses on certain occasions that are
completely independent of the customer
now you don't care at all about
demographics you just care about
occasions such as going out for ice
cream taking a vacation
whereas Coke famously did it being
thirsty cokes campaign doesn't care if
you're a man woman living in Uruguay or
Ukraine or if you have high
socioeconomic status or low all they
care about is are you thirsty
it's very simple and finally there's
cultural segmentation with this you'll
classify the markets according to
cultural origin now this can be
incredibly powerful given that
understanding a culture can give you so
much insight to certain groups of
customers and their behaviors now when
you use cultural segmentation you'll be
able to communicate well with a given
culture in the most effective way
no cultures can be large they can be
nation wide or they can be small and
reflect a particular regions such as the
Bay Area or even the startup culture
okay so now that we've talked about a
few different types of segmentation
behavioral psychographic demographic
Geographic occasional and cultural
segmentation let's explore how to best
segment your market